So far, we've learned to declare
optionals using question marks and
we've focused on safe ways to unwrap
if let statements.
Now it's time to get
a little reckless and
start working with exclamation points.
Unwrapping optionals with explanation
requires a lot more confidence in
your code.
If you try to unwrap a nil value
with an exclamation point, yikes.
To unwrap an optional in this care
free manner place an exclamation point
after the variable, but
if the value inside is nil it explodes.
Okay, nothing explodes but
it does throw a fatal error.
There's no safe way to unwrap
with an exclamation point.
When you choose to unwrap
with an exclamation point,
you're saying that you want the program
to crash if the value inside is null.
It communicates to your code readers
that you're confident there will not
be a null value in the optional.
You can also declare optionals
with an exclamation point
much the way we did with question marks.
But this optional is different.
It's implicitly unwrapped.
That means that when this
obstacle is used in an expression
it will automatically unwrap.
It is an optional so it can store a
value or nil but it's as if it's a very
fragile wrapped package that immediately
falls open when it's picked up.
Because we don't unwrap it carefully
if there's a nil value inside
bad things can happen.
A fatal error can be thrown.
So in what scenarios would
it be appropriate to
use such a volatile optional?
Let's look at a couple examples.